all right I'm going to play somewhere just
to relax and a Great Raid from Leon said
that was really fun
check one two
that's why I said all the Raiders off the
The Forgotten vcr and then they they stopped
self
I guess I'm just just just just to relax
second trying to supplement
I'm just relaxing oh shit that's right where
in down in this dungeon here
fuck so hard level I forgot about that
what do we have to do here and explore the
ruins and find the swallow symbols we found
the first one
yeah we found the first fall symbol is right
there I think so I think so Kara
all right well let's go see what else we can
do here
I need a light or something wait where's my
torch where's my torch
I know I have one I swear to God are you
oh mushrooms I play with your very slowly
don't anybody get excited
it's just so pretty scary going to climb up
there all by herself I should probably help
her carry do you help
a Cara Cara hey
why are you just wondering what you're doing
is just running race
I feel so sorry for Cara Cara it's up here
girl here climb up here it's not alright
fine I'm sure she'll make her way eventually
what year it's magic you did it it didn't
seem like you had it wait
I will be gone wait what's that it's another
swallow
I need to save it they need to save it
probably not wait what
I have a very bad feeling about this
I have a bad feeling about this it's going
to happen
wandering in the dark you give me damn ride
it is rather similar Cara
I think you're right I'mma light you on fire
my torch
it's not a euphemism a force that sold this
year
a Fortis or SAR is this language practice
what is this
it is it Allison for the horse Also let's
save
I know there's an easier way to say but I
don't know it I know it but I don't want to
do it cuz if I'm tired
I want is a mushrooms yes your heart is the
five oceans
good mushroomsgood mushrooms these days
where are you girl camera camera
hastily scribbled on with li oh shit
how the heck no I'm not alright I just about
died I need some beer
yeah I feel much better I eat raw meat in
beer
Robin beer I'm sure that will be fine
God damn I'm almost out of I'm going out to
do recipe
I'm I'm I'm sorry I'm selling out I'm
selling out I'm going to hear about this I
know it I'm putting recipe on
I know I'm a sellout a free recipe on
because of that recipe right resume makes
your food last forever it's got a cheating
so I can only tell you like a piece of raw
meat in the last for like 40 minutes safe
Care what's up girl yeah where we going
it's bad to carry your torture around cuz
well apparently that stuff is flammable I
did not know that
I did not know that was a very thing nope
okay down here
I'm going to bed here pretty soon myself
just relaxing a crazy ass day today
Isaac crazy day today we got a big ass to go
to 3000 1st and raid with bought a new car
week we got our communities fully installed
seems like things are things are happening
Whitewood Center I'm sure it's not safe down
there
wait there's a thing you see it
there is nothing down there I think I have
to go swimming should I take my clothes off
or just go for it I don't go for it
haha all right here we go hey look
yeah I would say so ways or something else
downstairs
I tell you I have to go down the water I
don't like swimming down the water it's
scary
as anything else in here well I got to go
down god dammit
Dive Dive Dive
way to meeting one of my other M that unless
I know which one is I can't remember
which one is d o c here we go
I don't have my cat eyes or anything I can't
see anything nor can anyone else who ate
baby
what is that what is that if something
so then please don't die I don't want to die
I don't want to die
this is very uncomfortable oh good good good
good good
I see white paint that's always a good thing
white paint is always good I didn't see any
any
treasure though all the best treasure is
always on the ground over there it is
there it is seriously the best treasure is
on the ground in the ocean
where are you there you are
yep there we go dormian sword told you and
I'm going to die
I'm getting kind of worried I am definitely
getting worried wait
oh shit Canario I was I was very scary all
right come on
come on, what should I say this ghetto.
Oh boy
okay
just a second puff balls together that looks
dangerous
that looks very dangerous
I don't know if that's going to be good to
go down there I guess so
all right what's opening all right
hi Karen cake going on I'm scared you go
first
how about we don't save game cuz I'm safe
all right time for bed soon
oh God
foreshadowing
oh God oh that's fine yeah yeah I mean I try
to
30 people at 80 you know and duh
meet him where they are hope we do we do
kind of pie it's it's it's easy to get
frustrated
oh God it's easy to get frustrated you know
it really is
at not even even with you do simple things
it's always like taking it where you are or
you know OSHA
you know what I forgot my this keyboard this
keyboard is messed up
god dammit
Mikey weapon my keyboard is messed up it's
got me stuck in Crouch mode cuz I pushed H
or something
wait am I not doing damage cuz I don't have
my right sword oh shit
it's like Dark Souls doesn't it feel like
Dark Souls
can I wonder if I got the right sort out
sweet punishment
ah
I know I know I know it's a to Yeti damage
if this if I were on meeting anyting if I
didn't have recipe out of me so dead right
now I still have my torso
oh
Dodge Dodge and roll dodging him in the butt
dodging hit in the butt dodging him in the
butt
take that you Golem
I know it seems like it's because I I know
because I was walking around with it like
doing stupid things all day
I am I sore. I haven't got to go to fix I
don't have a
I don't think I have a kid I don't think I
have a repair kit oh I do
do you have repair kit think I think I did
but I'm ready is it to what that was all
because my room is be hurting at 3 go
another run-through you know what's funny I
haven't I'm I'm doing this really slow just
for I'm getting all my gwent cards it's
taking me like forever but I don't care
Kara you little floozy where we can do now
girl
do exploring the ruins of all of the swallow
symbols all right let's look
it's just so pretty isn't it though this
game is just so pretty it's so pretty I mean
I just cannot get over how beautiful it is
it's just so relaxing it's the kind of thing
you can do right before you go to bed like
me right now
oh hey buddy holy shit that's a lot of stuff
I might actually do a lot more crafting this
time too I didn't do any crafting last time
anel
I didn't I didn't really do much crafting
last time
the crafty 4 armor sets yeah I didn't do any
crafting at some of the crap you could do is
pretty amazing I want to do that before I
like go for the mods you know
people people like jump for the mods kind of
early I guess Chris has a really good modded
outfit
I I wanted to Tris line to
yeah I know I was so disappointed I didn't
buy it I was so disappointed I was so into
it I thought it was going to be so awesome
and it really wasn't
I feel bad about that I do it could have
been so amazing to you it wasn't don't have
a storyline to try to roughly do the others
for the reason which was so great it's got a
really great plot
my pinion which is the only game that's made
me cry
the first run-through of Witcher I cried my
eyes that I got like a little snowflake baby
I I was so moved by the whole story line
between him and his daughter and then did
the tirade that destroyed us about standing
for something I just really got to me
I feel a nard coming on that's not hard or
is it hard
nope oh it's a climber thingy one of my
torch
it's not AAA title now it's really not I I
don't think it is
and I'm dying to Gears of War series yes
yes my
oh Astrid all the books she's she's the real
kind of sore she we were all into the games
and she read the books and she's she's like
Fountain of Knowledge when it comes to
Witcher
yeah you can spend we were going to get
there you're going to throw yourself in me
and I have to decide what to do about that
but a diversity of cp2
yeah that's one of the reasons I don't like
Dark Souls actually I just also I don't like
the look of this game the look of the game
is to my wife says it has too much black
into the ER at 2 in was too dark it's like
which are the which is just it's just
beautiful sister the sky that everything is
just gorgeous
guys considering look for it look at a wall
for like 10 minutes it's just got so much
detail in it you know it's it's just
everything that I always dreamed I was a kid
I mean playing his other games we knew it
one day that was going to be a
photo-realistic games at some point and
which is pretty damn close to it I mean it's
a bad winter in 2022 I can't even did you
see that they're going to do a cosmetic
upgrade for Witcher 3
somebody told me about that
it's actually his benches not to say no I'm
not quite it's great though
I love that they gave the call for adventure
in Ready Player One and that's why I like
telling people
about 18 people that our generation was the
first generation that made gaming mainstream
Gen X
it's true it's true Gen X Gen X was the
first generation that made it mainstream to
game
and yeah we're a tiny little generation that
doesn't have a lot to to to say uno
but the one thing we can say is we eat we
gave the world gaming
and we didn't we didn't solve The World's
problems with war or other stuff like that
but
we thought everybody had a wasted afternoon
after school I'm sucking right now
oh you got me I'm not a good daughter
what do we get in I guess we got him I wish
it that was a great example out of shit
I guess I followed her
getting Computing yeah with the seventies
right the Boomers gave us the cave is
Computing really
yeah
I I I I hate to say it but they did give us
a lot about some things actually one of
things I get home I God has some good stuff
right there
and one of the things that gave us was
definitely
definitely Computing computer to the
mainstream I guess that you could say they
give us a pcats we get we give the PC
it all right yeah we took that we took that
back I mean the Boomers left us with you
know this like you had to IBM people with
their sake no garters and their hymns and
you had you know how do eunuchs hippies and
the bell labs and it was still wasn't for
the bracket for the common person in the 80s
game is PCS no no doubt so
whoever you want a credit for it preseason
games
I know where we going continue to explore
the ruins where should we go girl I don't
remember
something I should do here I feel like there
is that's why I should get her but I feel
like I'm missing something
I don't know though a baby not maybe that's
just my imagination
it
I seriously I remember like playing with my
my 8-bit games and they can someday when you
be cool to like have a movie that you can
run around in and play
that's what this is what it is this is like
a playable movie
as long as you better right now just going
to get better play what movies are
movies are going to be the new normal
this is the NutriBullet yell at this crazy
is it they make you ever seen the numbers
are gold to look like called
so it's an art thing okay
I'm going to find it swallows yeah I don't
know it's going to be
the money that comes from games the gaming
industry is like 10 to 20 times more than
the money for a holic good Hollywood movie
including like all the Marvel shit
because there's so much money in it and I
don't know I feel like that's
the white hunt have a good detailing that
man
did you tell it's amazing
I really love it I mean I did surgery
modeling for a while
the simple stuff just like columns and stuff
I would take pictures of like actual rocks
and turned him into his models
this stuff is just so amazing I see the same
thing of World of Warcraft as I how did they
get that shot out of there there's no rush
out of there and it was like they did really
amazing things with low Prim with low low
vert in a resolution but this isn't this is
a real gentleman and I'm on low settings
Isis crazy just let me look it up I know I
sound like old guy right but seriously look
at that look at that
that's all computer-generated
it was my mind I'm sorry I
I think that one bit from that comedian is
like everyday we should be like every time
we fight as we oh my God I'm flying I'm
flying it's a miracle
that way we play games sometimes Frozen
oh I think that was a hint curate YouTube do
your your blouse up there girl it's little
and modest
then again we're on Twitch where every woman
is shows an accident out of cleavage except
for some there are some that don't
I feel a big boss coming on
the first time I saw the white hunt the wild
Hunt I was legitimately scared
did the armor they do in the wild Hunt this
armor is so fucking terrifying it's like
uh oh I probably save
all right after I saved
cuz I'm save scum I can't save my game
alright fine I should probably put the torch
away yes
why does he keep jumping forward I don't
want you to jump for it right here block,
block it
yeah guts can I get those guts Sulphur
wandering in the Dark Quest updated wait
wait
I mean we don't want to waste good sulfur I
mean come on damn it
anything from hell is made of sulfur
apparently apparently
hey Nicola Macarena
my boyfriend he don't want me the papa papa
papa papa papa
let's play doggies
oh you think so huh okay it's cold out here
it's cold
oh shit I need to get warm
what about my stamina what about my stamina
that comes later Cara
I was wasted Sulphur god dammit
I mean what kind of a what kind of
environmentalist Witcher am I
I got to pick up your your your waist and
pick your waist up
I would have the sofa lights on fire that be
cool huh
hey Macarena you know some Romanian saw that
so we're going to make her do the Macarena
and we're not going to tell anybody
we're going to tell everybody we're going to
just go to be our inspiration you'll never
guess it they'll never guess
I'm cold god dammit
where's my igni hey you know what they're
cold I bet fire hurts them what do you think
shit
and there you go has that barbecued oh shit
unskilled stamina what did you say uh oh we
found a glitch
there's a glitch
oh what kind of fruit do know
if you're fun and Brace
is she looking at her boobs
he looked down did you see that while he's
holding her and she's in the thing you like
takes a chance to get a nice clothes look at
her I swear to God did you see that
which are you naughty naughty boy
it's like now he was looking at her necklace
I'm sure that was it I'm sure that was it
here we go
I know but I'm not in a hurry is there tough
slog indeed
what's a slog exactly
waiters mushroom serve Kira-Kira you're
supposed to be The Alchemist check why don't
you grab all the mushrooms to eat you don't
care
who Waits us the elf dude
I see you is here waiting for I'm not going
down there without you
I'll go down there together orI guess I'm
going down all right here we go
all right I have a bad feeling about this
yo yo
scary dude who's not the main dude
got done with that armor
your dad I'm not dead yet
step back God damn it OSHA it
wait time for me to eat an infinite piece of
food you can say that again
oh my God that acts hurts so bad
I need a card son of a what watch your mouth
I mean there's no there's no reason for
vulgarities here
now I need I need the stunner where is it
Aki son of a baka
what do you speak in Tatooine he's remember
son of a baka
son of a baka they're pretty are all pretty
easy
oh shit geralt I need a key for these guys
it's so much more fun
it's so much more fun yeah you did
yeah that's right bring me that sulfur oh
shit
oh really geralt
Cinema Baca
Dodge my steps I might be laughing his ass
off at me right now my Dodge skills are so
bad
I got crit you see that crib yeah baby
that's my Catskills
o out
Iona Perry I'm going to Perry it's hard to
Perry he doesn't Perry that acts very well
son of a baka oh shit almost went in it
oh my God that doesn't look like it feels
too good you're dead
how are you
Shaw
how did you get back to health
I'll let you stick the same visitor geralt
Sarah Baca to you back oh shit that her eat
me like right in the skull
thank God my most important spell recipe is
working
alright what are we having to do this that's
how we're going to do it
I've had a gland gland what unnecessarily
Lesley Porter it's actually Laboratory
it is actually surprisingly I liked it a lot
holyshit I want that sword can I have that
sword can I has better sword
it is a surprisingly good
it is really is what would this was this
look at this fancy thing
-11yeah craft the stuff's always better
let's just be real here
Timothy o it was access to a crazy amount of
damage for how small are like a few if you
want to cheat at the beginning of the game
fix my thing Viper silver sword
wait what it's just a recipe with a fuck
I want to suffer
I want to suffer riding flash silver
I guess I can eat it I guess I can eat it if
I have to yeah like the fixer is a lot
and the writers on staff so all this extra
stuff they're doing is
I think okay kind of that makes sense
Mariana Luna just a second after I get all
the stuff
Terry there's a word
the witch beware the witches of crookback
bog
me to Cambridge is way better
yeah I don't have time to play either I'm
sure I'm just going to sleep or tell me what
time that's why it takes so long for me to
get there
do you know these witches
I can't play one into I've been ruined by
three I tried
fortnite not mess
yes
do they really
yeah
are they actually in The Witcher series the
Netflix series they actually have
gingerbread houses on chicken legs
they actually put it on chicken legs I just
I just caught that
I just caught that it didn't have that
before
the hole on top chicken legs think I'm going
to go straight for the book
Baba Yaga Baba Yaga holyshit
archgriffin decoctionGriffin decoction
I really got it Witcher the Elder blood
what exactly is Elder blood According to
some is a powerful of a pass from generation
to generation those in the veins of the
infamous air flows
are said to carry death destruction within
the oven to self hatred and disdain in the
hearts of many ways from the ocean is
contaminated blood
iklan yes
prophesied in Avenger would be born a
destroyer of Nations worlds other than the
other blood is extremely rare and here are
the whole Siri Elder blood thing is really
well developed in the television series
granted control over time and space to
degree unattainable even two elephants age
has sadly few Bears have this gift have been
able to control it in full this merely
partially Mastery inevitably leads to sudden
outbursts of power that take the form of
objective on control on this extremely
dangerous explosions that blow up obelisks
for example
yeah behind the Dark Legends about curse of
the Elder blood life's truths of these
tragic cases for obvious reasons burgers at
Builders Bears or the other would we're
always subject the greatest of the world's
Mighty and two midgets like the former
accounted on the truth if Lanes prophecy on
an Avenger being born who could
I don't know what's up I was just here
you're something else for us to find
I think there might be but I just don't know
where it is
well what Wate weather
I don't know it would obviously missing
something
I got the F2000 oh
maybe it's not a wall dude
now you didn't you just saying that
the eye of nehaleni why do they call it an
illusion
oh my God
are insufferable girl when you notice the
shipment of the Arawak towards it when you
press press e to dispel the illusion okay
alright let's try how wow
I said game saved it said game save so I'm
going to trust it may where's my there we go
are there any food here
no I don't I do see a nipple though
lamp what is my British accent you can
extend us and I said lamp dammit
set alarm for set of lamp sure
come then come then I'm going to go make
portals from now on
Havana Glen Cabela gland drag up
I think I'm going up I didn't repair my
sword though goddammit
where are we doing the whole thing, go to
bed it is a riddle I know what the riddle is
I don't want to do the real right now
I want to sleep
and on that note to my humble tiny group of
yours
we shall read and I'm going to bed
Kyra Peppa Pig I'm going to read sleep well
be well I feel like we should raid a a
Witcher streamer just to be
I don't read much but
how do I browse for Witcher categories I
know click on the thing that says Witcher
I'm smart it's so frightfully delightful
it's about how low was released in Icelandic
wasn't
I would have been kind of cool actually
it's only one point one k viewers of the
wild Hunt my God that's abysmal
wow toss a coin to your Witcher as it's
katzen she's on all the time
I read her the other day
we like chill people quit master
I don't know these people play Witcher
that's me
ask you who am I supposed to write him I
mean I have no I mean I have no opinion
about this
really I guess we could just randomly
pick some and she seems nice
alright was radar raid I don't
all right rage rage rage rage rage rage rage
bye
say hi to look at ass for me
do to do to do see I can be a good Witcher
twitch streamer by all